[Música]
os habéis planteado alguna vez cómo
gustaría que fuera vuestro futuro
o estoy preguntando realmente si en
alguna ocasión os habéis planteado cómo
os gustaría que fuera vuestra vida no es
tanto que queréis ser de mayor o cuáles
son vuestras aspiraciones a priori puede
parecer una pregunta complicada pero
no necesito una respuesta inmediata
únicamente que os toméis cinco minutos
para pensarla hoy cinco mañanas y cinco
la semana que viene
la familia de mohamed faruk
vive es una familia nómada y se desplaza
cada cada año se desplaza a una pequeña
casita situada
un balcón en las montañas de naranja
él conoce cada brizna de hierba cada
risco cada signo en la montaña o en el
clima pero sobre todo lo que necesitan
sus animales para comer
sin embargo 50 metros más abajo están
construyendo una carretera
que dará servicio a un nuevo hotel
me cuenta esto cuando lea una entrevista
con lágrima en los ojos
porque él se tiene que ir de allí y se
va porque nadie ha contado con él nadie
ha pensado
en preguntarle como donde se hace la
carretera y los desmontes de la
carretera los turistas qué
subirán a hacerle fotos el ruido y el
tráfico impedirán que su animales se
puedan alimentar
la situación de mohamed
es la misma que la de tantos otros que
al final sufren las consecuencias de
alguien que no ha pensado en los efectos
secundarios de su proyecto
pues bien yo llevo 22 años viajando por
todo el mundo y lo que me he dado cuenta
es de que fuera de nuestras fronteras
las cosas son de otra manera totalmente
distinta
aparte de que no te puedes tomar un
helado a 30 grados bajo cero simplemente
porque no existe la posibilidad lo que
sí es cierto es que fuera de las
sociedades que denominadas más
occidentales la gente dispone de tiempo
y el tiempo se utiliza de mucha manera
pero cuando abunda la gente reflexiona
la verdad que tenía una suerte de
aprender muchas cosas de hombres y
mujeres sabios algunos de ellos mucho
menores en edad que yo
que han tomado parte de su vida para
dedicarla a pensar y argumentar sus
reflexiones
esto
no ocurre aquí porque al final ha sido
la inmediatez y la
y la superespecialización las que nos
han hecho desviarnos de estos tiempos
que nos podemos tomarnos
nos han llevado a hacer que perdamos la
perspectiva global pero incluso a perder
la capacidad de adelantarnos a las
consecuencias de nuestros propios actos
a otro a otra escala tanto el banco
mundial como naciones unidas decidieron
implementar políticas de
descentralización en la sociedad nómada
simplemente porque era más sencillo
llevar la ayuda sin embargo nos hemos
dado cuenta de que alguien no ha caído
en el efecto que tendría esto y hemos
visto incendios que no se han producido
hasta entonces porque alguien no ha
pensado que esas decenas de miles de
cabezas de ganado estaban limpiando de
malas hierbas las praderas que recorrían
haber tenido en cuenta ciertos factores
nos ha llevado a sufrir las
consecuencias y a día de hoy se producen
a escala global llevamos siglos
cometiendo los mismos errores el
problema es que los efectos se van
acumulando
a día de hoy la globalización hacen que
los suframos todo y sean cada vez más
graves
sin embargo no todos los problemas se
producen a una escala tan lejana y aquí
por ejemplo en españa'
mira cuántos de vosotros tenéis una
opinión formada sobre la inmigración
seguro que muchos no pero cuantos
conocéis su historia o habéis puesto en
su piel conocéis sus motivaciones que
les han hecho salir de sus países de
origen o simplemente conocéis sus
ilusiones
no tener la capacidad para tener tiempo
para pensar nos ha llevado a que no
seamos capaces de empatizar
por eso las sociedades occidentales son
tan crueles porque tratamos a personas
que son iguales que nosotros de otra
manera lo hemos despersonalizado y
estamos hablando en muchas ocasiones de
inmigración ilegal cuando nos estamos
refiriendo realmente a que existen
personas que son ilegales
pero bajemos un poco más la escala
todavía vamos a nuestra vida
normalmente en la sociedad la que
vivimos
va al cole estudiar una carrera o dos
haces un máster o dos y busca un trabajo
normalmente con un mes de vacaciones de
casa y llega un momento en que empiezas
a cambiar tu tiempo por dinero hasta que
llega un día que no sabe muy bien cómo
te levantas y ves que algo no funciona
en ese momento mira a tu mujer pero no
la reconoce no es las chicas con las que
se escapaba un día entre semana para
irte a la playa porque estaba enamorado
de ella porque hubo un momento en el que
decidiste que era más importante cambiar
tu tiempo por dinero y así te ves muchas
veces con 30 40 o 50 años
con una con un par de críos con una
situación en casa porque no es agradable
oa puertas de un divorcio y en algunos
casos con o en muchos casos con un socio
en una sensación de inestabilidad
emocional o una depresión en el peor de
los casos entonces en este momento
empieza a buscar desesperadamente algo
que te que te dé la felicidad pero no
sabes lo que es porque hace muchos años
que no te hace esa pregunta
estos son efectos que se derivan un poco
del sistema en el que vivimos
tanto a nivel personal que nos lleva a
no ser felices como a escala global
donde al final todo acaba girando en
torno al crecimiento económico la
extracción producción y distribución de
materia prima
pues bien a lo mejor mi experiencia ha
sido un poco distinta en este caso sí es
cierto que cada vez que salgo de
expedición pues aprendo un montón de
cosas
pero recuerdo que en el año 2019 fui a
documentar la locura pakistán una etnia
nómada que vive en las montañas y me
llevé una lección de humanidad no
solamente a través de ellos sino de toda
la sociedad paquistaní empiezo a pensar
que tenemos un problema grande en europa
aquí ya no tratamos bien a la gente
mayor nos distanciamos de ellos nos
separamos y muchas veces lo acabamos
metiendo en residencias
es hoy uno pasa ellos los integran en
sus vidas y esto especialmente duro
cuando se realizan las migraciones
porque tienen que cargarlos vestirlos y
alimentarlos mientras van avanzando
de alguna manera podríamos pensar que
tal vez esto sea un problema de falta de
humanidad que no lo es pero también lo
que nos ha pasado es que hemos dejado de
vivir dentro de un modelo familiar
colaborativo donde todo el mundo ayudaba
a todo el mundo
a día de hoy en europa nos está pasando
que la mayoría de las unidades
familiares las componen únicamente la
primera línea de parentesco eso nos hace
tener que tener tres casa en lugar de 13
teles 3 sofá etcétera y no para de
preguntar bueno si son malos sobre todo
ahora que se estimula tanto la
independencia pues no no es malo si tú
lo puedes permitir lo que sí es cierto
es que es poco sostenible y que al final
nos lleva a pasar prácticamente toda
nuestra vida cambiando tiempo por dinero
para conseguir las cosas que se supone
que necesitamos
así que quizás deberíamos de volver al
principio y volver a hacernos la
pregunta que no es que quieres ser sino
que quieres en tu vida y dedicarle un
tiempo de reflexión a las cuestiones que
realmente son importantes y si para eso
necesitas sacar un papel y un lápiz por
los acá apuntan los pros y los contras y
por intentar llegar un poco más lejos
intenta alcanzar a ver las consecuencias
que se derivan de tomar una decisión u
otra
nos pasa muchas veces sobre todo en esta
sociedad que él
la acumulación del conocimiento teórico
nos lleva a pensar que somos mejores sin
embargo la mayor fuente de conocimiento
en la experiencia sobre todo la
experiencia propia y la pregunta es
donde están nuestras experiencias
vamos a hacer una cosa cerrar un momento
los ojos
imaginad que tenéis puesto los pies
sobre una capa de nieve de 20 metros
recortado contra un cielo plagado de
montaña veis la silueta de un caballo
estás en santervás un paso de montaña
situado 5600 metros en una de las
cordilleras más altas del mundo el
karakórum
detrás de ese caballo es otro y luego
otro y después de otro
350 bestias de carga que van en fila
abriendo huellas a 2.500 cabezas de
ganado y detrás de ellos las familias de
naranjas que la componen 300 individuos
en una migración de 1000 kilómetros
desde una remota región de cachemira
hasta el parque nacional de 26
en una imagen brutal no
pues mi experiencia o mi motivación es
la de estar allí y verlo con mis propios
ojos
la verdad es que he tenido la suerte
creo yo de vivir en muchas ocasiones con
nómadas y siempre he aprendido un montón
de cosas pero principalmente aprendió
sobre mí mismo
porque cuando dejas la mente libre las
cosas se vuelven mucho más sencillas en
lo que los alpinistas llaman claridad
mental cuando están en la cima de una
montaña
lo bueno es que esta montaña de la
puedes traer a casa y para hacerlo lo
único que necesitas es eliminar el ruido
mental que nos acompaña día a día
así que tal vez nos podemos preguntar
bueno es posible cambiar nuestro modo de
vida
con la respuesta desde mi punto de vista
es un condicional es decir fuera del
sistema únicamente están los nómadas
puros que no necesitan nada de él no es
nuestro caso pero si nos paramos a
pensar un momento quizás nos demos
cuenta de que hay un montón de cosas que
no hacemos por miedo que tenemos y que a
la postre nos impiden resolver nos
preguntas tan sencillas como qué quiero
en mi vida
así que yo lo que propongo y que creo
que funciona para poder hacer esto es
tomarte cinco minutos al día para pensar
de manera consciente y otros cinco o
diez dejar que se te un consciente el
que te guíe
fomentando también la autocrítica porque
si expandes tu manera de pensar si no te
limita únicamente a hacer arte ideas
absolutas
por ejemplo salgo a tomarme un café con
un amigo y empezamos a hablar y llega un
momento en el que la conversación pues
se pone un poco tensa no a lo mejor
porque él tiene una idea que es
totalmente opuesta a la mía
quizá lo que podría hacer es en lugar de
confrontar la es escuchar lo tenga o no
tenga razón da igual volver a casa
volver a la conversación ponerme en su
situación y tratar de defender su
argumento
a lo mejor no puedo hacerlo porque mis
principios son otros pero sí que es
verdad que ese proceso me va ayudar a
aumentar la perspectiva que tengo
y me va a hacer que caiga en cosas que a
lo mejor antes no he tenido en cuenta
qué pasa cuando nos tomamos un tiempo
porque al final te acabas enfrentando a
ti mismo a tus miedos
a tus ilusiones
y las pones delante
y
eso empieza a hacer que te desarrolla a
ti mismo que tenga conciencia de quién
eres y empezar a deshacerte de esos
miedos que son los que te impiden
responderte de manera libre y las
preguntas que te hacen
así por ejemplo cuando
decidamos hacer un proyecto tal vez
podemos pensar que la familia de mohamed
faruk no tiene por qué abandonar el
refugio de su antepasado a lo mejor
hemos caído en él y tenemos una solución
para su situación
pero podríamos llegar incluso más lejos
a integrar todo el conocimiento que él
tiene de su entorno y de la montaña él y
su familia dentro de nuestro propio
proyecto que seguro que crecería
así que la pregunta sería que queremos
seremos capaces de darnos cuenta de qué
muchas veces dejamos nuestros sueños a
un lado porque siempre tenemos algo más
importante que hacer
seremos capaces de eliminar el ruido
mental que nos acompaña en nuestro día a
día por ejemplo el uso compulsivo de
redes sociales
y sobre todo seremos capaces de darnos
cuenta de que hay un miedo que llevamos
dentro que muchas veces no nos deja
hacer prácticamente nada
pues eso es así enfrentamos no a ese
miedo que es algo que única y
exclusivamente depende de nosotros
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]